provoked strong reactions from both
president biden and vice president
harris nancy cordes is in nantucket this
morning where president biden is
spending the thanksgiving holiday nancy
good morning
good morning dana you know president
biden never made any secret of his
thoughts about this case early on he
said that arbory had been gunned down in
cold blood now he's praising the verdict
even as he expresses regret that arbory
is not alive today to celebrate
thanksgiving with his family beyond that
the president said while the guilty
verdicts reflect our justice system
doing its job that alone is not enough
instead we must recommit ourselves he
said to building a future of unity and
shared strength where no one fears
violence because of the color of their
skin
vice president kamala harris the
nation's first black vice president and
the former california attorney general
she weighed in as well she called out
the defense lawyers one of whom at one
point you will call complained about the
number of black ministers in the
courtroom she said quote the defense
counsel chose to set a tone that cast
the attendance of ministers at the trial
as intimidation and dehumanized a young
black man with racist tropes the jury
arrived at its verdicts despite these
tactics now in addition to the guilty
verdicts yesterday these three men are
also facing federal hate crime charges
they're accused of targeting arbory
specifically because of his race and
those cases are expected to be heard in
federal court in february vlad
all right nancy cordes with the
president in nantucket thank you nancy